I'm not an expert in this like
disrespect thing
but if if she felt disrespected then the
bar is low
y'all get disrespected over everything
because basically she felt disrespected
when Michael called her bro now I
understand the older generation that's
like a generational thing that's
disrespectful to them now but there's
levels right because you can control
your reactions today I could understand
being annoyed I can understand having a
conversation with him after
but
what I don't understand is getting up
threatening the whole room
over this disrespect and somehow I was
disrespectful because
she kept trying to over talk me the host
in my
Studio on my show